der schutz israels und seiner existenz
gehört bekanntlich zur deutschen
staatsräson jede form von antisemitismus
sollen nicht toleriert werden nicht nur
deutsche antisemitismus denen es immer
noch und immer wieder gibt sondern auch
muslimischer antisemitismus deshalb hat
die bundesregierung
2021 an den filmen gefördert der sich
genau damit auseinandersetzt hat aber
offenbar nicht hingeschaut in einer der
hauptdarsteller dieses films der einen
radikalen muslimen darstellt spielt
diesen nicht nur sondern er ist es nach
bild recherchen offenbar auch hier ist
doch ganz genau das gewesen dass man sie
geld auf der welt dann wusste ich doch
nicht mit dem was war deine sachen du
bist ein drittel der film ein nasser
hund basierend auf dem buch und der
persönlichen geschichte von ari charouz
ali k im film geht es um den jüdischen
iraner so haye der von antisemitischen
muslimen ausgegrenzt wird nach angriffen
auf ihn verschweigt er seine jüdische
herkunft eine weitere hauptrolle spielt
sein freund musste ihn radikaler muslim
und antisemit gespielt von muhammad ali
aguilera ki ist auch im echten leben
israel hasser nimmt an antisemitischen
demos in berlin teil ein skandal mit dem
sich unsere bild redakteuren judiths
passat beschäftigt der
hund wurde staatlich gefördert und es
geht darin um eine sehr amüsante
geschichte und zwar um einen jungen
muslimen der um einen jungen juden der
heraus wir sahen 1 gesetzt ist und dann
seine jüdische identität verleugnet weil
er sich bei den jungen das leben
integrieren will das problem ist dass
einer der hauptdarsteller mohammed
lartey gesehen worden das bzw es
videomaterial gab das ihnen auf
antisemitischen hetzfilm muss zeigt hier
die beweise bilder von anti israel demos
in der hauptstadt auf mehreren videos
ist der schauspieler muhammad ali rafi
klar zu erkennen zwischen menschen die
sich antisemitisch äußern
die zur gewalt gegen israelis und juden
auch in deutschland aufrufen der film
ein nasser hund ist staatlich gefördert
150000 euro von der bundesregierung auch
die deutsche filmförderung und das
medienboard berlin brandenburg
unterstützt den film es ist kann daran
der sache ist dass man hier einen film
hat der staatlich gefördert wurde und
der auch deswegen gefeiert worden ist
weil er eben dieses problem das wir
haben das sich am wochenende wieder
gezeigt hat von antisemitismus im
muslimischen milieus antisemitismus der
wirklich ausgeübt wird von jungen
muslimen weil sie da ihre identität
finden dass so ein film der das zu
klimatisiert ausgerechnet ein darsteller
aus diesem film dann auch solche demos
geht also er hat sich quasi selbst
gespielten dem film und was sagt ari eva
rust alica auf dessen lebensgeschichte
der film basiert zu diesem skandal
alica hatte damals aufgrund von juden
anfeindungen die im film thematisiert
werden seine heimat berlin verlassen es
ist genau die art radikaler muslime
weswegen ich berlin verlassen habe falls
er teilgenommen hat dann bin ich mir
nicht sicher ob er mein buch und somit
den film verstanden hat er sollte als
junger schauspieler lieber für frieden
und gegen judenhass werben leider sind
solche skandale kein einzelfall
es ist ein skandal an dem wir von bild
selbstverständlich dran bleiben und über
diesen skandal und auch über kommende
anti israel demos hier in deutschland
kommen wenn dr elio adler dem
vorsitzenden der werte initiative
jüdische deutsche position sprechen ich
finde es extrem frustrierend dass jemand
stirbt an einem film mitspielt der
eigentlich für den brückenbau steht der
eigentlich den zusammenhalt von
minderheiten fördern soll die eigentlich
gegenseitiges verständnis wecken soll
dass so jemand sich an die seite von
israel hassen antisemiten stellt und
vielleicht wenn man an der seite steht
ist man innerlich auch gar nicht so weit
ich weiß es nicht aber man es selten in
der nähe von leuten denen man sich
innerlich sehr entfernt fühlt es zeigt
leider dass das unrechtsbewusstsein das
bewusstsein einfach etwas grundsätzlich
falsch zu machen da überhaupt nicht
ausgeprägt ist im gegenteil es wirkt so
als wenn die typen stolz sind ihren hass
zu verbreiten
diese ideologie des hasses scheidende
szene ist so ausgeprägt zu sein dass das
alles andere übertönt wird sehr
frustrierend bezüglich der angekündigten
anti israelischen demonstrationen morgen
noch haben sie nicht stattgefunden wir
haben großes vertrauen in die
sicherheitsbehörden dass sie nunmehr
spätestens nach den vorkommnissen der
letzten tage ihre konsequenzen daraus
ziehen und warten dass erst mal ab
der antisemitische demonstration in den
letzten tagen in deutschland wieder